that that that that that you guys up
here today I'm going to learn how to
create boobs out of nothing
two-dimensional boobs Kylie Jenner did
it and something happened it's kind of
artistic drag queens do it I'm actually
kind of excited they told me I had to be
hairless for this so we brought in an
esthetician ah we actually didn't have
enough money to toot the full session so
we waxed part of my chest I need to put
a bunch of foundation all over my
breasts ivory yeah I'm like an elephant
hey I'm a warm beige there you go US
Census I was never yellow I'm beige I
didn't ask if I was allowed to rub
makeup on my freshly waxed body and I
have a feeling the answer is absolutely
not oh [ __ ] spilled everywhere is it
look any blue that's good it's covering
up all the little bloody pores about to
decide how big my breasts are I can have
stereotypical Asian breasts or like my
family's Asian breasts which are very
large then there are different sizes but
that's accurate
you look like boobs yet nope honey and
almonds man Winnie the Pooh is gonna be
after these titties this looks like
blood and poop I start over looking from
far away they look awful I failed
painting in college it was the one class
I ever failed my entire life like using
shadows and light contouring was
invented in the Renaissance does this
look like boobs or open-heart surgery
yeah look at the size of those melons
I've had enough of this I'm gonna get
some green no I've got a happy boobs
yeah I don't know how to put on a bra
sexy are you doing the sexy one oh yeah
it looks great
they're way too high up but that's just
perky I think I did a terrible job my
boobs are too far apart like I had a
whale bone necklace and then got super
Sunbird right here I would not look
twice at my own boobs
a little different this time around you
think you can do better I don't know ask
yourself out feel like right now my
chest sort of looks like do you see two
faces or do you see a face a bit Keith
that really nice-looking boobs
well it's amazing what you actually put
them together oh that's how you blend
you just add some abs while you're at it
honestly my chest looks like my butt how
often is this used I like to suggest
contouring really just for like
photoshoots boobs boobs boobs boobs is
there like anyone if I just showed them
like this subs like today that's some
sexy boobs and be like psyche got Punk'd
whoa suckers Wow like the more I look at
it the more I'm just like yeah like I've
always had boobs of course Eugene
probably looks like a fox though because
you slender like a lady already obey a
seams action look cute I will say this
looks hilarious just focus on this not
on my belly cuz they all jiggle just
crazy can do that with what's
essentially paint okay you know those
are my yeah you have boobs different
things I can just walk up behind you and
grab them my sisters will be proud this
is made me realize that not every boob
is what meets the eye think I can get a
nice man to buy me a drink there may be
some trickery behind the Moo berry it's
been a weird day
1 2 3
Sigrid Junior's look way too convincing
back wait is your hair go yeah I did got
rid of it you're into this so confusing
400 no it is a gag reflex come on
someone's at least a little turned on by
this